what's that believe nation it's Thursday
it's awesome to be here I have made a
commitment to trying to be with you here
at least once per week on a Thursday the
answer questions either myself doing
this Q&A with you guys or I have a guest
on and so it's time to do another a mas
our fifth one I'm super pumped to be
here you guys know the drill
leave your questions in the side I'll
try to get through as many as I can
let's do it let's get into it first up
kuba kuba
pop-pop-pop-pop kiosk Wow hope I
pronounced it okay how to always believe
in yourself it's a great question I
think it comes down to two things I
would say one by showing yourself that
you can do smaller projects you can work
towards bigger ones I think that by
writing my first book about and write my
second book with a lot more confidence
with a lot more belief how do I get the
confidence write my first book why I
wrote other articles before right it's
like every little step that you do daily
consistently allows you to take one more
step I don't think you just go from
nothing to some huge thing overnight I
think it's a continual process of
pushing yourself a little bit further a
little bit further a little bit further
expanding your comfort zone a little bit
more a little bit more every time and
every time you do that the stuff that
used to be scary used to be in your
comfort zone here right because it's so
small I got that stuff that's easy
what's in there now that's so easy for
me to do and so training yourself and
getting used to being in that habit of
doing something every day to push a
little bit more I think is really
beneficial I think it starts in the
morning
I think people hit this news button lose
I think you've you've trained yourself
first thing in the morning that you've
set a goal to do something and you say
no I'm not gonna hit my goals today I'm
gonna fall back asleep right and and I
think what that does is it trains you to
realize that you can't hit your goals
boom I said I go I'm gonna wake up at 8
o'clock 7 o'clock 6 o'clock
hit that snooze button I've just trained
myself that it's okay not to hit my
goals it's the first thing I do every
single day right that's what a lot of
people do is so what I do but it's what
a lot of people
do and so that's you you're training
yourself to let yourself down you're
treating yourself that you cannot go off
and hit your goals and guess what you're
not gonna hit your goals you're not
gonna believe in yourself
to be able to do it because you're
setting up the wrong habits and so I
think the first part is creating good
habits stretching what you feel you're
capable of on a consistent basis in
small little tiny increments right again
it's not going from if you want to be a
speaker it's not going from speaking to
a room of three people this speaking at
Madison Square Garden so full-out
stadium like that doesn't happen like
that it's the constant slowly everyday
building up to be better than you were
yesterday I think the second thing that
helps at least me believe in myself is
the environment that I'm in right like
this these people are in the wall for a
reason they help me feel believe the
expression the clothing reading the page
from the book the book came out guys go
pick up a copy of the book I'm so
excited that finally you guys get a
chance to read it came out yesterday
great tough feedback so far but I mean I
read a page in that book every morning
because it's from there's two rules from
some iconic person like Steve Jobs
putting his thought process into my head
because if you're not surrounded by
greatness around you on a regular basis
or worse you're surrounded by negativity
you're surrounded by people who tell you
that you can't do this and it's really
hard to fight against it right you're
likely to succumb to it and feel like
you won't be able to do it like you
can't do it and then you won't believe
in yourself so having a powerful
environment having powerful routines
whether it's watching videos or reading
a book or going to have a conversation
with somebody like whatever the thing is
it gets you feeling that boldness that
belief in yourself for me it's reading a
page from the book and it's watching the
videos that helps me like I make these
videos for me right the top ten that we
put up like Lisa Nichols went up last
night I loved it like that was for me
and I'm so fortunate I can share with
you guys and so if you do that if you on
a regular basis everyday start to take
one more step further out of what you're
comfortable with instead of one step
further in by hitting the snooze button
and letting yourself
every day and then to Krita environment
and rituals around things that make you
feel confident and believe in yourself
like books like videos daily like that's
why I wrote this book is not plow
through it and read the whole thing
because you'll get hit with so many
great ideas and then you'll fall back
down which I hate that when that happens
to entrepreneurs right we're on top of
the world feeling bold and confident and
then we fall back down so I want it
daily I want to deal E in my life I
wanted even in your life a consistent
reminder to stretch a little bit more a
little bit more a little bit more so
that the people around you unsupportive
you can still grow and reach your
potential
welcome everybody we got the questions
flying through I love it if you tagged
me it's a lot easier from you the sea so
let's see what we got Diane bean and
sorry guys it's chance coming in so
quickly that you might have asked a
couple times when I'm starting to finish
up my last question it's a good chance
and that's what Diane bean good morning
Ivan no snooze here high-five Diane I
love that thoughts on how to re-engage
former clients I haven't kept in touch
with some for months some for years
easing direct-mail thoughts so one I
would say don't over complicate things
just contact them hey I've been thinking
about you how you doing just like a
genuine reach out there's a there's a
number of people who've reached out to
me after after years and it's great to
hear their name a not so what a more
famous example is Ryan Holliday who we
did some work together with when he was
at American Apparel and I didn't keep in
touch with him like five years later he
writes to me an email says hey Evan I
know we did some work together before
just touching base seeing how you're
doing
let's hop on a chat I'd love to be able
to connect and we did and it led to me
doing work with this firm it led to
getting some promotion for your one word
let the him comment on my channel led to
him opening up connections for me to
various media publications like we
helped each other out a lot and that's
just because he reached out to me after
five years of not reaching out so I
don't know that you need to worry so
much about the marketing the brand
in a position now that like you could do
that it's a longer-term play but just
start with reaching out one at a time
phone call email with with genuine care
that you haven't you haven't been in
touch with them for the past X number of
years or months and you're wondering how
they're doing the the pull way the one
on the the marketing branding side is is
just creating content and a lot of
people get back in touch with me because
they keep seeing my stuff right maybe I
want to get a speech somewhere three
years ago in whatever country and people
are still I'm I'm still on their radar
because they keep seeing my videos they
keep seeing my social media posts like
I'm a Content machine constantly putting
content out and so that allows me to
stay top of mind with them even though
they're not top of mind with me because
I may not be following them and what
they're up to but they're following me
and so having a strategy of creating
consistent content I think will help you
but it's a longer-term play like it's
not gonna just final in business
immediately I think your best bet is
just to reach out don't make it don't
make it too complicated just a sincere
outreach like it'll make a big
difference what do we got what do we got
what do we got
Jason Shem oh I have a nutty hit when
millions YouTube subs what's your next
big goal thank you for that Jason I'm
still working on it to be honest it's
one of those things that when you hit a
goal I think at least for me I hit a
goal on and I kind of get depressed not
the press but a little little sad like I
okay
I hit that goal I even I even reached
that point before hitting the goal once
I knew that the goal is achievable then
it lost interest for me so my goal and
she was eight million YouTube subs by
the end of the year and at the beginning
of the year I wasn't gonna make it at
the begin of the year I was I was not on
track to hit the goal well I wasn't
getting enough new monthly subscribers I
hit that goal and so the go kid got a
hustle got a hustle oh my god I'm gonna
make this I'll probably hit it in
January February but I want to hit it
better of the year then as we picked up
steam I realized I'm gonna hit it I'm
gonna hit it the first projected date
with was Christmas and then December 18
and this
number 15 and then December third and
then and then it ended up being in
November so once I realize that I'm
gonna hit it that I would have to Royal
II mess up like I'd have to just really
forget to put up videos and even if I
didn't put up videos I probably still
would've hit it this year I'd have to do
something just insanely stupid to not
hit the million once I realize that then
then the goal was not interesting
because I already in my head I already
achieved the goal so I've been thinking
about this for a while it's not just
yeah we hit it last week two weeks ago
for me the next logical one was hitting
ten million and I'm still working
towards that it's it's a it's a far away
playing it's not gonna happen next year
and so that that's a little that bums me
out a little bit and so I'm trying to
think like how can I make that happen
next year and it led me to some bigger
thinking around what's a big goal that
will never expire what's a big goal that
I'll never reach what's a lifetime goal
that I'm shooting towards and it led to
a massive rebranding of my website if
you go to my home page now you'll see
it's about untapped human potential and
how I see that working and this is a
lifetime goal for me and where it ends
up I'm not a hundred percent sure to be
honest I'm gonna be investing in
businesses I'm going to be starting new
businesses I'm going to be continuing
with my youtube channel and doing other
things but I'm still figuring that what
that path looks like so right now I run
my company I run China dance salsa and I
run a lily I'm invested in Lily's
business and helping her build her
coaching practice the goal is to build
that to a million dollars plus and then
I've invested in a couple other
entrepreneurs who are just getting
started and I'm doing some partnerships
and I'm looking at making some other
investments too and maybe acquired some
companies and just seeing how it all
fits for me to figure out internally
what I want to build myself and what I
want to partner with people on there's a
there's a abundance of opportunities at
the moment which is a great problem to
have but it leads to a distracted focus
so I need to figure that out as I move
along my path though I will keep you
guys updated thank you for the love
Jason I appreciate it
what do we got I name's e evan hi any
advice on how to get out of a rut yeah I
think a lot of I think a lot of people
are in a rut I think most people live in
a rut everyday I think that's I think
that's 90% of the world you just get up
and you go to a job you hate and you're
living for the evenings and weekends and
that's your life for me that's your
entire life is in a rut and so how do
you break out of it I think the first
part is just acknowledging that you want
something else that you want something
better and that is within your control
to go and do it I think as long as you
are blaming circumstances you're blaming
your government you're blaming your
education you're coming up with some
other excuse you're blaming your parents
you're blaming something as long as
you're stuck in that world where it's
not your fault
then you stay in the rut as long as your
parents fault or your countries fault
you stay where you are
you're never getting out because you
have somebody else to blame as soon as
you blame yourself not in a bad way not
gonna like I suck away but in a this is
on me and nobody's coming to save me
this is on me to fix nobody's coming to
get me to 100 to 10 million I said 100
million subscribers I like that nobody's
coming to get me to 100 million
subscribers right like I need to go off
and do that once you realize that then
that's a starting point to make real
change in your life because until then
all the strategies all the tactics all
the books all their whatever is not
gonna help you until you get over that
mindset I can give you the steps 1 2 3
do these 3 things but if you don't have
the mindset that it's on you to do it
you'll never execute those things so I
think that's number one I think - then
you got to figure out something that you
are passionate about or can be
passionate about and if you don't know
what that is and you need to explore you
say yes to a whole bunch of things
something is interesting for you you
just follow your curiosity you don't
figure out your passion sitting on a
couch and dreaming about your passion
you don't figure out your passion like
flipping through a magazine of different
ideas you don't figure out your passion
by looking at ynx magazines hundred
hottest startup plans for 2018 like
that's not how you find your passion you
do stuff and you see what makes you come
alive just
like if you're dating you don't find
your your wife just looking at a picture
online like you have to actually go out
and meet her right you got to meet this
person have a first date maybe have a
second date you know get to know that
person and see if you want to go back
it's the same thing you have an idea you
have something curious it's something
interesting something tantalizing go out
and try it like that should be your new
test as soon as you get an idea you go
out and try it in some kind of small way
just to get a taste just to see if it's
something that you want to keep doing
and if it draws you in you want to keep
going back and back and back and back
then that's the seeds of a passion that
you can turn into potential business
when you get enough skills on it it's so
interesting that once you find yourself
doing work that you love even if you're
not making money yet but you're doing
work that you love your immense your
immerse re and something that you just
absolutely love doing how much that
blows into the rest of your life how
much you won't feel like you're stuck in
a rut anymore how much all those
negative situations suddenly disappear
because you are happy and so I think I
think first off recognize that you have
to have the mindset that this is your
responsibility to get yourself out
you're not blaming anybody else for
where you're at and then - exploring
exploring exploring until you find the
thing that you love doing is so so so
super important and will help you get
out of your rut and then just a third
quick point just making it consistent
just so it's like you don't listen to
this you get all fired up and then
tomorrow you're back in you're right
like every day you have to do something
every day whether it's a video that you
watched it gets you excited or reading
the page in the book or whatever it is
something every single day you need it
because too often you'll have like one
day that you're super jazzed up and then
the rest of the week you're not and you
do like the winners win because they're
consistent because they get up every day
and they do this thing that they love
right and they grind away at it where
you could be the most talented person in
the world but if you're not working hard
at it you're not gonna win so that's my
advice what do we got chart your tray
what job try your trade thank you for
picking up a copy of the new book I saw
the message I love it I appreciate it
trigger trade what things would you try
to make sure
you have in place before taking a leap
to take your business full time for me
what I would try to make sure is that I
have a way to sustain myself I'm not the
kind of guy who says quit your job go
all in you know like throw garbage on
your boss's office and like have no no
way out and like burn all the boats I
think I think I would want to have a
spot where I'm making enough money to
survive not not to really live a great
life but to survive like to pee the
internet bills and to eat ramen and just
be able to survive once you get to that
point like if you can create your
business on the side weekend's evenings
lunch hours you know all that you can
create your business on the side to the
point where it can sustain you then I
would quit then I would quit my job and
go off into my business full-time
because if you can get to that point on
a part-time business and imagine we can
do full-time the challenge is I think a
lot of people jump too soon a lot of
people jump one because they hate their
boss and they hate their job and they're
not in a job where they're learning
first off get a job where you're gonna
learn something don't get a job that's
totally unrelated like you get a job to
learn not to make money so get a job
where you're learning something people
quit too soon they go all another
business and they can't get it to the
point where they're making enough money
through their business and then they've
run out of runway
they run out of money their bank account
doing those two nothing and then they
have to go back and get a job three
months later which sucks I don't want
that for you I don't want that to happen
that's what happens to most people when
they're starting the business and they
quit their job when they try it so I'm
much rather you do it on the side get
enough like whatever that number is for
you figure out your your mortgage cost
your car your car cost your internet
costs and you know obviously you want to
keep the cost as low as possible I was
eating beans for lunch every day figure
out what your costs are and then when
you hit that number part time when your
business then you go full-time
it's my thoughts what do we got
immanuel how do you reach out to the
decision maker when trying to present
what you can do for his or her business
without pitching to the gatekeeper first
so couple strategies here one I think
the easiest way to get right to the
maker is through social media I've had
the most success through Twitter it's
still not guarded a lot by gatekeepers
sometimes they are if there are really
huge big celebrity then their Twitter
can't will be monitored and guarded and
they won't be replying but you'd be
surprised at how many even CEOs have a
Twitter account that nobody interacts
with them on and you can get through to
them and just interact with their
content thanking them for sharing again
I wouldn't just pitch right away I'd be
involved with what they're writing so
follow them for a couple weeks interact
with what they're saying comment on it
retweeted make a make a I love making
video responses every morning I spend
half an hour on the bike in the gym and
I'm I'm doing it on social and I'm
making video responses on Twitter for a
lot of that I think it's personable and
a good people great way for people to
get to know you and so I think it's an
untapped market right there if you're
trying to reach business people look if
they have a Twitter account and try to
get in touch through that if they don't
have Twitter then you can go through the
other social platforms if they don't
have that then it's finding some other
way in so as an example I wanted to get
Howard Schultz from my book he's the guy
who started Starbucks I wanted him for
my one word book because he his one word
is love and a huge brand you know one of
the most recognized brands in the world
and he wasn't he's not on social
personally it shocked me it shocked me
that he was not on social so he doesn't
have a Twitter account it doesn't have
the it doesn't have you know needy
accounts that I can get through but I'm
not gonna go up the corporate chain like
it just takes way too long to get a
decision so imagine like right into you
know whatever press department at
Starbucks I just imagined choking on the
pile of garbage from years trying to
forget figure out my way through that
path and so I was looking for a ninja
ways to be able to do it and buddy mine
Jay helped me figure out all the
different paths and all the different
research one example was so he has a
fund that he started with another guy
and the other guy runs a fund that guy
is a
on Twitter like can I reach out to that
guy get to know him and get an
introduction to Howard right looking for
all those kind of loose connections the
one that ended up working was he so the
book that he has I don't have it here
it's called onward was written with
somebody and I love the book and that's
where he says that his one word was love
and that Starbucks is based around one
word love great I wrote to the person
who co-wrote the book with him and it
was this woman and she that's what she
does is her business ghost writing books
co-writing books and she's not that
popular like she's not a household name
she posts on Twitter she has an account
right that's a win but people don't
really know her she doesn't really have
a lot of engagement so I reached out to
her and said I really want to thank you
so much for the book it was tremendous
value I loved it you know maybe I took a
picture of the book or some highlights
and just a show that I was actually
reading it and built a relationship with
her and then I mentioned that you know
fellow author I'm trying to write a book
I love the message in one in in on words
I love that you've wrote that his one
word was love I would love to try to get
an interview with Howard to talk about
love for my book and because I had built
up a relationship with her
she made an introduction to the global
head of global head of something for
Starbucks and long story short we
couldn't make the interview happen in
time for the publication date for the
book but that was my best into really to
move it forward and so it's looking for
a ninja strategy so you're not dealing
with the gatekeepers and I think social
is your easiest way to do it but don't
just spam them provide value first and
if that's not working directly then
figure out who's one connection away and
provide value to that person and they
can make the interaction for you there
we go what do we got
Anna inna I want to thank you for your
hard work and great work it's priceless
I write bachelor thesis based on your
work very cool I want to see that
bachelors thesis thank you for the love
Chris how do you act in quotes when
negotiating with first sponsors I don't
know what you what you mean by that to
be honest I did I'm myself
and I'm not acting like anybody I think
when you're working with sponsors I was
just giving somebody advice or leave
today on this one I hate I hate reaching
out the sponsors two reasons the first
one is I'm spending my time reaching out
the sponsors instead of spending my time
actually growing my business so I could
be making more content I could be making
better content it could be doing more
research I could be making another video
for you guys like this you know I could
be spending this this time here instead
of doing an AMA with you reaching out
the sponsors I hate that it takes away
from the business of what I'm actually
working on and to when you reach out to
sponsors you lose control like you don't
have the power anymore right you give
them the the authority you give them the
leverage and so my strategy and that and
it can still work it works for a lot of
people just the way that I do it is I
would much rather build a magnet to
bring the right people to my business
not just sponsors sponsors partners
investors fans customers suppliers I'm
oh I want to build a magnet that people
want to come to me and so that's why I
really value the time of creating the
content because I make content it's
consistent we do three videos a day on
the channel and that brings in attention
interest awareness and that leads to a
ton of opportunities including brand
deals and so I would much rather spend
my time actually working on the content
and building up more of my marketing
machine then trying to do outreach and
hoping I find the right person and then
when I do having to convince them that
I'm the guy to work with
again it's like swallowing months of
garbage instead of actually doing a
thing that you love doing and so that's
how I built my business sales is a path
it could work for you but it's not the
one that I prefer going after what do we
got what do we got more questions hit me
up this stuff coming in if you do if you
tag me it's a lot easier to see in the
comments
so attack me just type in at Evan
Carmichael
so next CJ Jordan what is the one piece
of advice that change your life the one
that was the first one I guess I had a
huge impact on me besides my parents
saying you know you're having
Christopher Lee Carmichael you should
believe in yourself which was huge I
would say as Jeff Bezos who talked about
regret and living his life without
regret and he was you know I think this
story in there Jeff Bezos in there I got
a look he was a high paid guy on Wall
Street making tons of money was the
young sever VP at his firm and he left
it all to go to Amazon to sell books on
the Internet and he drove the Seattle
and he wrote his business plan for the
company as he was driving from New York
to Seattle just sounds crazy
you gave up you gave up the life to do
this and everybody thought it was nuts
like who's gonna but what's the internet
who's gonna buy stuff on the internet
people who buy books online that's crazy
what are you talking about
so isn't a very early adopter and and he
said you know what I just couldn't live
my life with regret of wondering what if
and he calls it the regret minimization
framework very very engineering like but
basically to live your life to try to
have as few regrets as possible fewer
regrets as possible and so that helped
me a lot in when I was deciding to go
for my first business where be making
$300 a month versus taking all these
amazing job opportunities and I thought
I always wanted and earning six figures
and all that our Jeff's advice is in my
head thinking what am I gonna regret
like am I gonna regret if I don't go off
and do this business yeah I would regret
it what I regret not taking the job a
little bit but I always knew I could get
another job it may not be that job I
mean it'd be that company may not be
traveling Asia like one of the jobs was
offering me may not be the same level
awesome but I could get another job if I
wanted to this business I didn't know if
I'd ever get a chance at it again and so
I had to do it so I had Jeff's advice
kind of ringing in my ear that I had to
go off and do it and so I think that
that advice has served me even to this
day if I ever feel like I'm gonna regret
something we rarely regret the things we
do you usually regret the things you
don't do all right almost never I mean
you'll have some regrets the things that
you said or things that you did that you
might regret but for the most part are
regrets of the actions not taking and so
I still use that philosophy today I my I
did that first when I was 19 I'm now
what yours it 37 so 20 years later
almost and it's still one of my go-to
piece of advice if I'm gonna feel like I
might regret this not taking action that
I have to take action even if I'm afraid
to if I'm scared if I have no idea how
it's gonna work out I have to do it
because I don't want decades of regret
ahead of me so that was a single best
piece of advice
next Ryan do you think you're great some
college reflect the success you've
achieved now no not really what did I
get in college so I mean in high school
I sudden suck but I had B's and C's for
good chunk and then in my last year for
whatever reason my own expectations of
myself exceeded my parents and I got
straight A's in my last year high school
and then I got when I got the university
what was my GPA I had like a 3.72 or
something like that which is decent not
not amazing not not sucking either but
I'd started my business when I was in
university so I kind of already checked
out of the idea of getting a job right
when I turned down those high-paying
jobs I was in my third year no second
year I don't remember but I've already
kind of checked out like University is a
great place to give you the skills to go
get a job at a big company if that's
what you want to do then it's fantastic
and go and do that and then your grades
really matter you know you you want to
take care because
that's what they're benchmarking that
being said other activities
entrepreneurial activities count for a
lot too I got interviewed with McKinsey
as an example which is a premier
consulting company paying six figures
out of the gate and I didn't have the
highest GPA there but they loved that I
had Australian experience and they hired
people you think this would be a hiring
business students right because it's
business consulting but they had art
majors they had math majors they had
science majors and so some companies
really value the diversity of experience
and some companies just look at what
your GPA is and that's who they want to
hire some companies only look at what
University went to and that's who they
hire so just depends in the hiring
process of the company in terms of
starting your own business I think the
biggest benefit of going to university
one is the people that you meet so
like-minded young people who are off you
know you get to have friends you get off
and you go do your own thing and as your
careers grow they they grow in
prominence that their companies or they
start their own businesses and it gives
you a network of people to connect with
and to it teaches you just discipline
and rigor and practice for a lot of
people a lot of people a lot of my
friends have a difficulty going from
high school to university high school
was a lot people were a lot more on you
a lot more structure your parents are on
you and then you go to university and
you're free yes you have to do
coursework but you're more free and so
you need the self-imposed discipline
thing to go off into the work and I
think that can serve you well as an
entrepreneur because you're free you
have to put in a lot of work but there's
nobody above you saying you need to do
this yes our customers sure okay but
like day to day why do you get up and
work every single day's because you you
want to you need to get that drive to do
it and so some of the rigors there the
discipline could help you and I think
it's also just a good backup plan if
your business doesn't work out if you
find out that you don't want to be an
entrepreneur it's a lot harder to get a
job if you just have a high school
degree versus your University of degree
but if you're looking at my success or
in my business I it wasn't really
helpful it wasn't really valuable
apart from connecting with the two
people that we started this business
together and that was my first success
right some more the people there then
the actual coursework I remember doing a
fourth-year course on entrepreneurship
and it was really it's just a joke
because I was already living and
breathing it and so the material there
most of the time in class I was I just
had my laptop open working on my
business not really paying attention to
the professor and the professor to
didn't really wasn't really not to
preneur it didn't really have much like
book knowledge not actually out there
having done something so I think it
depends I think if you want to be an
entrepreneur the benefits are limited I
think if you want to get a job at a big
company then you almost have to so if
you know what your ambitions are then
you can map your actions towards it next
Johnny why is the engagement of your
channel subscribers so far apart and
what are you doing to get more
engagement why is the engagement of your
channel and subscribers so far apart so
Johnny it's the it's the quantity of
content most people aren't making three
videos a day and so I don't need and
there's a video on this if you look in
the description of most videos I talk
about it but I don't need you to watch
every video I don't expect people to
watch every video I don't want you to
watch every video like do work right
like get something from this ask the
question learn and then take the
information and go do work if you're
sitting on YouTube all day long then
you're not building your dream and doing
the thing that you you want to do and so
most people who are my size or even just
in general most of the most youtubers
aren't creating the kind the level of
content that I am and so if you look at
my channel size so we just crossed some
end subscribers compared my channel to
most channels that are a million
subscribers and look at the growth that
we're still getting right now and look
at the number of views that we're
getting
I bet um ahead and so people just focus
on the wrong metric if you guys are
starting up on YouTube do not folk
is on views per video or engagement per
video it's the wrong metric it's the
wrong metric if that's what you're
tracking then make one video a month and
you'll have awesome views for video and
engagement per video but you're gonna
lose on YouTube so you have to
understand the game that you're playing
and then reverse engineer it to give
yourself the best chance of success and
that's why I'm able to pass people on
YouTube who I feel have a lot more skill
and talent than me or who are better
speakers in me I give them all the
credit in the world like they should be
destroying me but they're not because
they don't understand YouTube as much so
for any of you guys out there who are
youtubers stop paying attention to views
and engagement per video it's a wrong
metric jo-ann hi do you agree with the
saying it's better to be kind and to be
right it's better to be kind than to be
right I don't know that's too black and
white I think there's too many there's
too many
there's too many gray areas in some
cases it's better to be kind in some
cases better to be right and again I
think I think the right metric there is
looking at it from their perspective and
what is the thing that they need to hear
if I look at Alex for example someone
who are mentoring in my my Toronto
that's also business sometimes he needs
me to be kind to him sometimes he just
got beat up and and not physically but
just he's hard on himself he wants to
drive further he's not accomplishing the
goals that he wants for himself and so I
need to remind him to be nice to himself
so he needs to be kind and sometimes if
we're talking about something that's
really important for his growth and
development he needs to see that I'm
right because it's for him because if I
lie to him and then he stays where he's
at instead of getting to where he wants
to be that doesn't serve either of us so
I don't think you can make a black and
white rule on that one I think you need
to understand the context and I think
the most important thing is that you're
doing something out of service to the
other person not out of benefit to you
so that's where that's kind doing
service to the other person instead of
being right for yourself
I just interpret it when I hear it as
like
right for them right be kind for them or
be right for them
depends next what do we got what do we
got where we got t-mac how do you figure
out what the cell as a product when your
business is primarily a cause based
business just figure out where the
problem is right so if I look at what
I'm doing like I consider myself to be
in a cause based business I'm trying to
spread belief how do I do that what's
the best expression of that
well I start with the videos I start
with the video content because I like
consuming video content but it's not
it's the best because it's what I like
it's what I can get engaged in why am I
not having a podcast podcast is a
fantastic business strategy it is a lot
of you guys have had love comments you
should have a podcast it's not what I
enjoy doing at least right now maybe
that will change but for now I don't
enjoy doing podcasts I like being a
guest on a podcast but I don't want to
have a weekly show for myself I'm much
for the new video I much rather do this
live with you guys and so that's a great
strategy but it's not a great strategy
for me so you got to find the thing that
you love doing that ties in to the cause
and solves a problem right gear t-shirts
right apparel I like wearing this stuff
I don't wear it just when I go on a live
stream or making videos I wear it during
the day because I love it because I feel
like a superhero entrepreneur putting it
on this book I didn't want to write this
book the top ten rules for a long time
because I felt like I talked about at
the top of the show that people would
blast through it and it wouldn't get
value from it they would get value but
then it would drop off like much more
because much more important than reading
this and a week is the daily but I
couldn't think of how that would happen
until I came up with the idea of one
page a day what if we read one page a
day and then you absorb those two
lessons are gonna learn and apply it and
I tried it myself and I was getting the
boldness I was getting the feeling it
was making me think and so I thought
okay this is working for me I don't
recommend stuff to you guys without me
having used it I just got a brand reach
out to me yesterday
we want to sponsor content and be a part
of your channel like great I'll be happy
to check out your company one I don't
recommend or work with companies that I
don't actually use their products so I'd
have to use your tool and it has to work
for me
because I'm not putting my name on it
and saying I endorse his business if I
don't actually use it and then to here's
how I work right here's my fees here's
how the structure works you have to be
bringing value to my community not just
trying to sell them something if you
want me to be a Salesman for your
product that's the wrong approach if you
want me to be a brand ambassador we're
gonna find a way to give value then
you're you're barking up the right tree
and so you know what your cause is
within that cause so I you know believe
in people right I want people to reach
their true human potential within that
cause there's a lot of different
business models a lot of different
people doing different things which is
and they're all awesome what is unique
to me like what can I bring that is
different than I enjoy doing and for me
it's what I am doing right it's making
videos for you how am I able to be
consistent in still two three videos a
day right because I love doing it if I
didn't love doing it I would burn out
most people would jump into my schedule
and burn out because it's just too much
work right can you imagine doing three
videos a day it's nuts it's crazy how do
you do that writing a book is no joke
now I'm done to write in two books is
you have to enjoy the process you got to
enjoy like creating a book and not every
day is amazing in other days that I
hated write in a book but I like the
idea of having a book I like the idea
that you guys would have something that
you could have in your hands and read
and it would really help you in your
business and so that's it I would stop
trying to be so opportunistic and
instead lead more with the heart less
with the head and more with the heart
figure what you need what do you want to
see and then go make that and yes there
has to be the main for it if there's no
demand you just have a hobby something
that you're passionate about but that's
the start if you just look at the
opportunity just look at the market I'm
just trying to fill a need you're not
really going to build anything special
because the people who love doing that
thing that you're doing they're gonna
crush it so go do the thing you love
doing within your cause next
yo spec you expect hope I get that high
if I have the chance to change my life
but I should miss because my parents do
not want me to change my life what do
you advise kind of getting the general
sense of that question so one at some
point in your life you have to figure
out is this your life or is it your
parents life this is your version of
your life or your parents version of
your life and as you are young it's what
your parents want for the most part
right your parents say go to piano
practice you go to piano practice your
parents put you in soccer cake you go to
soccer camp you only have a choice when
you're five years old what you're gonna
do right hopefully as you get older they
respect it a little bit more and try to
give you customized programs to help you
my son Hayden here he's eight you know
he's in the art I suck at art art was my
worst subject but he loves art and so
almost every day I'm drawing with him
right
like we're drawing Harry Potter comics
and we're drawing League of Legends
characters and we're just drawing and
it's something I do with him when we're
looking at putting him into art classes
things that I don't know about but I
want to support him on his journey he
doesn't have to be an entrepreneur he
does have to be in YouTube where he
doesn't have to be an investor in the
businesses it's what he wants to do but
if you're not you don't have those kinds
of parents then at one point you decide
that this is your life and you're gonna
make your own decisions and you're gonna
live with the repercussions of that is
it 20 years old is it 30 years old is it
16 years old
you know the pro is like you decide and
you start making your own life the con
is you have to live with that you have
to be able to deal with the fact that
you may get kicked out of house you may
have to go find your own place your
relationship with your parents might be
damaged in the short term that's part of
making hard decisions right and so
that's your decision to make those back
to the very first question
self-confidence and belief it's not your
parents life for you right you just
accept that and as long as you're
blaming your parents for the situation
then you have somebody to blame you're
not reaching your life because it's your
parents tell you you can't you just
haven't been willing to accept the
compromise accept the downside that they
may not like what you're doing and that
may mean you don't have their support
and that mean you have to move out can
you live with that can you accept that
can you deal with that right chasing
after your goals and chasing after your
life is not easy and that's why most
people don't do it because it's safe and
comfortable where you are you know
you're in a house you're with your
parents you get food you get things paid
for it's not maybe the life you want to
live but it's also not crap you're not
on a bench in some Park so if you want
to live a life that you want you've got
to be willing to give up the things that
don't serve you and it doesn't have to
be immediate back to Mike's question
earlier like when you go full-time start
part-time start doing your thing on the
side until you get to the point where
you can move out and go off and do your
own path but is accepting responsibility
that this is my life it's not my parents
life it's not my friend's life it's not
my guidance counselor's life it's no
nobody around mieze life it's on me and
you are where you are because you chose
to be there and when you choose to make
a different decision your life starts to
change next James haven't you outsource
any part of making these videos do you
owe us any part of making these videos
great you ask it twice James uh depends
we need my outsource so I have a team on
the YouTube side of things in this
business I have eight people on my team
some of them are local some of them are
not local I don't consider it
outsourcing because I consider the
people to be part of my team so more
like so if you had an employee on your
in your business is that outsourcing no
I consider more delegation so I wouldn't
say that I outs or
anything on my YouTube videos but I
delegate a whole bunch almost everything
and that what that's what's helped me go
from one video a week to a video of
three videos a day right
the first hire made was getting an
editor and that let me go from one a
week to one a day because I sucked at
editing I just I just took me too long
to edit and then I was able to continue
to build my team to the point where now
we can do with three videos a day it
still takes me a lot of work I'm still
reviewing all the videos that go out I'm
still giving my feedback and thoughts
and comments and training my team but
yeah if you want to go far you need to
go with the team whether you go the
outsourcing path I think if you're going
to be doing this seriously I think
outsourcing is not the way to go but
delegation and just making that mindset
shift because when you outsource
something you just kind of let go of it
someone else is taking care of it when
you delegate you're still in charge you
know I'm still responsible for what
everything my team makes you know yes I
pay someone on my team to edit the video
and publish it on time for this
morning's and espresso right Tony
Robbins interested in what lied this
morning I didn't press the submit button
on that video right I reviewed it I
helped name it but I didn't press submit
if that video doesn't go up it's my
fault even though it's somebody on my
team or is responsible for doing that i
delegated it to them it's my fault if it
doesn't go up ultimately so just accept
the responsibility for everything
happens in your organization is super
important Sarah what is one daily
discipline you recommend that keep the
haters out of your head uh so what is
one daily one daily discipline if I had
to pick one daily discipline I would say
to do something that surrounds yourself
with people who are dealing with haters
on a regular basis so I think for
example if you wanted to learn to be
more confident I think I don't think the
best thing to do is read a book about
how to be confident because it's too in
your head
so if you watch a video or read a book
on here are 8 ways to deal with haters I
don't think it's gonna help you as much
as being around the people who are
actually dealing with haters I think if
you can feel it it's much more important
than if you can know it if that makes
sense and so I think if you want to be
more confident better than reading a
book on 7 ways to be more confident is
watching videos of people who are
confident and by watching them and being
around them you will become more
confident just like if you are hanging
around negative people all day long if
you are hanging on complaining negative
people all day long you won't need to
read a book about how to be negative you
know how to be negative because you're
around it all day long and on the flip
side if you're around people who are
positive all day long you don't need a
book around how to be positive like you
need books on how to be positive because
your your around negative people all day
long and so it's why I created the
mentor me series on my channel and even
the top 10 because I wanted to be around
people who are doing game-changing
things who are thinking on a different
level and the more I hang around them
regardless of what they say regardless
of what their rules are just being
around them seeing them seeing how they
act seeing how they think seen how they
react the things builds up belief and
confidence in myself and a great example
that I like to use as Elon Musk was on
CNN or some big radio or big TV station
and was off saying that artificial
intelligence would destroy the world the
robots gonna kill us all and they asked
him how is that gonna happen and he said
I don't know and they asked a couple
more follow-up questions is that God
enough can you imagine I'm trying to put
myself in that position I go make this
big bold claim and then the natural
thing people gonna do is ask a follow-up
question and I don't have the answer I
think most people would stumble to try
to find an answer because you don't want
to look stupid on national television
but for him saying I don't know wasn't
looking stupid and just watching that
clip I don't know how to verbalize that
in a rule right I don't know how to
verbalize that in a book but see
that clip changed me a little bit and so
if you really want to get over dealing
with haters a daily discipline I would
look at is what kind of content could I
consume my preference would be video
where I'm around people who have to deal
with haters on a daily basis and they're
doing it well
whether it's Taylor Swift and shake it
off or somebody else there's a great
Steve Jobs video about haters I would
try to consume as much of that as
possible
and yes some of the strategies might
help you but more importantly just being
in that environment consistently will
help you realize that the haters don't
matter that would be my advice you asked
her 1 the second thing I want to give
you a bonus the second one that I found
really helpful is just feeling empathy
for the person instead of being hit and
triggered by it just feeling empathy
like what kind of person look has
anybody left hate in this in this chat I
mean we have genuinely good community
but it's got to be somebody's left hate
now I'm looking for hate come on did
somebody leave hate there we go look
okay Neo zero
why are you bald right great question
near zero thank you for giving me a
great example like what kind of person
do you have to be to come on to a live
chat like this and leave a comment like
that like how bad does your life have to
be that you get off trying to put
somebody else down and I just try to put
myself in their shoes I try to imagine
myself as being neo zero and that this
is the the greatest part of my life is
being able to go on somebody's live chat
and leave a negative comment like how
sad of an existence does this person
have to have and and by reframing it
that way I'm not angry I feel sad I feel
sad for that person like I really wish
that neo zero had something positive to
contribute to the world because he's or
she is not happy and that sucks and so
that may be another strategy
you can use has really helped me thank
you for giving us a great example near
zero next dbo Saha being emotional is it
good or bad for entrepreneurs so with
having a conversation with Alex on this
actually yesterday I think it just
depends on how you're using it I think
if you're a robot it's bad I think using
emotion for positivity is good I think
making emotional decisions from a
negative perspective is not good right
so I look at my content now compared to
when I started on YouTube five or six
years ago the difference is the content
is almost the same like my points are
almost the same I've grown and learned
new things I talked about that and share
new stories but my delivery is the
difference the passion behind what I'm
saying is different and passion is great
like you need it to bring people along
you need it to get yourself moving
forward on that big mission that you
have and so you need to have that
emotion if you want people to follow you
on some crazy journey that may or may
not work out that nobody else has tried
before then it's your emotional
commitment to what you're doing one of
the things I express all the time to the
people on my team all the time look lily
and Alex both yesterday I was telling
them the difference is your emotional
commitment to the words that you're
saying you can be saying the best words
like you could take the best speech of
all time and say it in front of a class
but if you don't have the emotional
commitment to what you're saying the
words will fall flat or you could have
crappy words but if you have emotion
connected to it you will move people and
so that's the difference I think it's
really important to have the emotion
behind what you're doing strong reasons
why when you communicate there's passion
behind your voice that's why it doesn't
matter if you're ESL or English is your
second language or you have an accent
like those things don't matter you can
have the person with the best perfect
English with no passion and they will
lose versus somebody who if you guys
watch crazy Russian hacker youtubers
like over 10 million subscribers or
something like that
crazy thick Russian accent but is so
into what he's doing that it doesn't
matter you're sucked in by his passion
not how well he says once the specific
specific word and so that's what really
makes a difference now if you're on the
negative side if you let the negative
energy run you if you are making
decisions that you feel guilty of
because you say something that you
regret later that's not great and so
it's learning to when you know it's the
right thing to do to be energetic and
passionate from a positive perspective
and try to when it's on the negative
side restrain think about it again the
thing that helps with that is just the
other person's perspective somebody made
a huge mistake at my business it's my
fault right ultimately maybe I didn't
train them right maybe I hired the wrong
person it's my fault I'm upset at myself
but I talking to them I need to think
did I did I explain this clearly enough
you know that I did I walk them through
enough for the steps like why are they
making this mistake are they just
careless are they having a hard time in
their life you know like their dog died
or they had a situation at home and
they're they're not sleeping properly or
did they just not get enough training
that they try to do something out of
initiative and just did the wrong thing
without knowing how we operate
you know there's usually a reason most
people are not malicious you know your
work with people on your team they're
mostly not malicious they're not trying
to hurt your company they had a reason
to do it and so understanding that
recent can help with the the negative
side a little bit more what do we got
how did the ad pocalypse that affect
your channel how do you find time to
play League of Legends we are so busy so
those are two different things but I'd
pocalypse didn't affect my channel at
all I guess it probably helped my
channel because the advertisers come to
me instead of going to wherever they
were going why I don't have content of
kids being abused you know I don't have
spider-man dressed up doing crazy things
to Elsa right I don't have that kind of
content
I'm you doubt the swearing on my videos
I've done that from the beginning
people ask me like why did you do that
as if your ad pocalypse go back to my
channel I've never had swear words on my
channel one I don't swear personally I
don't have anything against someone who
does it's just not something I do and I
don't want to I don't want to share that
and I want like I know people with kids
watch your channel my son will watch
videos on my channel I just don't want
that on my channel that's fine and so a
lot of the videos that are getting
flagged so I had a video with with Tom
bill you get flagged because I think he
swore a couple times in a video he was a
guest so I didn't I can't it's life
right that's fine so I'm not making
money on that video but in general my
videos are good quality content that
wouldn't offend advertisers so works out
well for me and then finding time for
League of Legends I think it depends a
lot of times when I'm playing league
it's to get my mind off of something
else so like if I'm if I'm a classic
examples I'm trying to sleep and I can't
sleep I got something racing through my
brain I find that playing a game of
League of Legends helps me because I'm
so focused and immersed on that game and
I want to win and then I forget about
the business problem that I'm wrestling
with that's preventing me from sleeping
and when the game is over I'm calm
because I just had an intense experience
now it's over I can relax and the
business problem that I was thinking of
before is gone I might have to think
about the next day but find that
relaxing some of my friends places good
bonding Haydon likes to play it was good
bonding I remember he first played his
game when he first game when he was five
and I played a game with in League of
Legends you play five five people
against five people or five people
against the computer and we got into a
game together and I had you're matched
up with three random people so if I was
on a team and we're against the robots
so no not against real people and I was
confident in my ability to be able to
carry the whole game just in case
because the robots get easy after amount
of time so I messaged everybody on my
team at the
you're paired with three strangers hey
guys just want you want to let you know
I'm playing this game with my son he's
five
so don't flame him don't don't really
pay attention to what's happening
because he's he does his own thing he
runs down and dies just so they can live
and like get the boots of speed right
like he he plays a game with his own
objectives but don't worry we're gonna
win I'll carry the game and somebody
wrote back in the comments I'm playing
with teenagers mostly like you're the
best dad ever
that was a fun play League anyway so uh
I don't have a set time where I play a
league it's more out of something just
fun to do or something that I'm trying
to get my mind off of and so it's a good
way I find that I find that better than
meditating playing a game of League
distracts my focus and then I can ready
to go to bed guys we're coming up on an
hour I want to really thank you and
appreciate you for spending this time
with me I'm doing two more live hangouts
today on my other channel if you want to
check it out come out some questions
there I'm gonna try to keep this
commitment to you I have fun I enjoy
doing it once a week on a Thursday we're
trying to keep it at 11 a.m. Eastern and
looking forward to seeing you guys again
soon hopefully you have an amazing day
carry this energy forward into your
business because I believe in you and I
want you to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love guys
thank you for all the love thank you for
the support on the new book those of you
who bought on launch day yesterday and
more today I really appreciate it
have a great rest here Thursday and I'll
see you soon